how can you hide in plain sights on the  internet well spam can actually help  with this yeah really everyone's  favorite spammy males and so let's get  to work on your camouflage our lives are  all going to be online forever so just  get used to it there are accounts from  which you simply can't delete yourself  and we'll talk about this in the  following videos however you can create  an invisibility cloak for yourself with  Spam how I'll show you that's strangers  from around the world to your friends  join groups that you aren't interested  in share posts that have nothing to do  with you using your email create fake  adverts register on a bunch of dating  sites and trading platforms change your  age and place of residence upload photos  of non-existent people to websites and  sign them with your name in general bury  yourself under a big pile of spam and  use it as camouflage from search engines  subscribe and I'll tell you even more  about cyber security in the online  jungle